what's going on guys this is rob and
just in time for the eternals film it
looks like marvel's basically reworking
the history of the eternals really with
uh with modifications to their existing
origins as well as how their origin ties
into thanos uh which makes sense because
in all honesty the eternals have not
really been relevant or interesting in
marvel comics uh probably since like the
mid 2000s right when you had like the
eternals run that tied in with what was
going on with the x-men and like the
return of the dreaming celestial and all
that kind of stuff outside of that they
weren't relevant before that until like
heroes reborn and maybe like the 80s
before that but they've only had like
five year points right five year windows
where they mattered and then they would
just disappear into obscurity forever
and nobody would really care anything
about them so here's the thing this was
kind of crazy about this one of the
things that kieran gillan has been doing
here has been focusing on the idea of
expanding on the mythos but also
basically giving us this idea that that
there was a kind of schism that took
place among the eternals now this was
not something that we were readily
familiar with in fact it's not really
something marvel's ever really explored
at all the way the normal timeline of
the eternals played out is that they
were created by the celestials a million
years ago that they were supposed to
basically safeguard humanity from the
deviants the eternals basically deviated
from that partly because they didn't
care and partly because there was a
civil war that broke out between uranus
and kronos where basically uranus wanted
to conquer earth and kronos wanted to uh
basically want to be peaceful and so
ultimately uranus lost they were cast
into space they took up residence on
saturn's moon titan where they fell into
another civil war and then all but sweet
son were destroyed we'll talk about why
she matters here in a minute but in
terms of being on earth that the
eternals could never really reproduce in
the same way that humanity or even the
deviants could and so because they were
being outnumbered by the deviants and
because the deviants had enslaved
humanity they called the celestials back
the celestials basically initiated the
great cataclysm right so the sinking of
atlantis when the deviants attacked the
celestials and then the celestials won
the eternals if you deviate from your
role again doing whatever you have to do
right because you literally have the
power to use cosmic energy your job is
to make sure the deviants don't run awry
if you deviate from this again we will
destroy you all and so following that
the eternals basically maintain their
role of kind of shepherding humanity
safeguarding humanity from the deviants
from that point going forward until such
a time as like people with power started
popping up right the x-men blue marvel
the century you know incredible hulk
spider-man fantastic for all these guys
and humanity could basically protect
itself and so this schism is introduced
based on the premise of the fact that
eternals didn't really have the ability
to reproduce and that's where this new
civil war takes place that on one side
you have alars and you have icarus and
you have all these eternals that are
siding with him over the desire or the
idea that eternals should be able to
procreate in the traditional sense right
like you guys know how this whole
process works right that when a mom and
a dad really want to have a baby they
call the stork and the stork brings the
baby and then they you know raise the
child as their own you guys know how the
reproductive process works and so
because of this it's one of these things
where this war has really split the
eternal community on ideological lines
that on one side icarus believes they
should be able to procreate on the other
side it's not really working that way
that you have zeros who is really the
leader of the eternals on earth at the
moment who believes that the eternal's
role was prescribed for them by the
celestials and by the great machine
right now the great machine again we
talked about that during the the
beginnings of kieran gillen's eternals
run that the great machine is basically
what keeps the celestials alive right
it's how they resurrect whenever they
die and if the great machine were to
somehow break down malfunction be
destroyed it would destroy the earth in
the process it seems more like a
fail-safe device assuming that would
even actually happen thus the eternals
believe it because that's what they were
told but we've never actually seen an
instance where the machine failed and
earth was destroyed with it because it's
a new thing right it's never really been
pushed to that point before and so
because of this it kind of creates a
cool situation right it's like what
happens if you don't press the red
button and then suddenly when you stop
pressing it who knows what takes place
right is everything going to end or will
things just continue on because it was
really more of an experiment to see will
you just do what you're told and so this
kind of civil war here is ultimately
brought to an end by what is basically
you know dana right the mother or at
least the the wife of kronos and the
mother of xeros and a large right now
here's one thing to understand when it
comes to eternals because of the fact
that they can't really procreate in the
traditional sense they were all
basically made at the exact same time
the term mother father those are
loosenet terms those are terms to design
or to define the roles within the
eternal family right so if you think
back to like the early days of humanity
you had kings and queens imagine instead
of calling that person a king you would
call them father and instead of calling
her a queen you would call her mother
right so it's just really a hierarchy
among the eternal race but the idea is
that they still have a kind of authority
there that's recognized by everybody
else and so as they're allowed to air
their grievances xeros and lars anyway
and as they're allowed to discuss and
kind of have this great big huge debate
on what it is it should be allowed to
happen the response of dana is okay so
here's what's gonna happen one alarms
you're going to lose this war and the
damage you do to the great machine will
be catastrophic all the way to the point
that you might even destroy the entirety
of humanity you do not have the numbers
and you cannot complete your research
while this war continues and that she
says use xeros you will win given time
but many defiant eternals will end up
being excluded right and we'll talk
about what exclusion means at the end of
this because it's something that they've
referenced that we've never actually
seen before and so she says you say you
want to protect the machine but all
exclusions heard it and so in effect
elars cannot conduct his experiment
without basically dooming the world and
xeros cannot oppose the experiment of
alarms without basically reducing the
eternal population down to almost zero
which in turn would allow the deviants
to rise again the celestials would show
back up and they would basically destroy
what's left of the eternals they would
probably kill the deviants too and then
wipe the white to slay clean on earth
and just start all over again and so
ultimately dana says here's what's going
to happen because of the nature of this
and because of the fact that neither
side can really win without some kind of
catastrophic loss ulrs you'll be sent
away from earth to a place where you can
conduct your experiments you can do your
thing and you xeros will stay here and
you'll guard the great machine and
you'll keep things as part of the status
quo right you'll keep things the way
that they've basically always been and
so in doing that all these eternals that
have been engaged in war with one
another if they've died they're
resurrected and if they're alive their
minds are wiped but basically it's all
started all over again right this is the
normal process when it comes to the
eternals it's still a kind of relatively
new thing but it's the process with
eternals if you are an eternal and you
die you get resurrected now sometimes
your mind is completely wiped and
sometimes it's not it depends on the
circumstance under which you died but
the important thing here is that alar's
is basically like he ends up taking off
right he's basically about to leave and
when the question is asked of him by
zoros where are you going to go his
response is i'm going to go where
there's the last eternal left right at
least the last eternal that's not on
earth i'm going to go to saturn's moon
titan and i'm going to meet with this
eternal and then hopefully we can find
some way to reproduce and that's when he
meets suicide now again sui-san was the
last survivor of the civil war among the
eternals that had left earth that would
follow uranus and then basically
destroyed themselves in a civil war now
the reason why they fell into a civil
war was weird it was like the dragon of
the moon and it was this crazy thing
there's a reason why kirin gillan
doesn't really acknowledge that here he
just says like a conflict broke out and
they all died because even then the
whole idea of the dragon of the moon was
kind of silly it was it was a little
nonsensical but the important thing is
that when he arrives here one of the
things to know is that suicide despite
how she'd been depicted in years past in
marvel was always kind of battle
hardened you always sort of expected
that right that at the end of the day
she is an eternal right so her power
here the ability to manipulate cosmic
energies super high level capabilities
right super strength speed durability
all that kind of stuff she's way beyond
your normal human despite the fact that
they look human and they act human
they're way beyond what humans are
normally capable of but they're very
human in terms of how they work because
at their base they are humans right and
so following that as soon as mentor
arrives who are really a large changing
his name to mentor when he arrives here
he starts talking to sui-san and the
whole thing about this is that as they
discuss this he talks about how the
civil war that broke out here the fact
that she's the last survivor left like
any great thing in this in this universe
that she's basically been reduced down
to her strongest foundations so you can
basically rebuild it is in some ways
manipulation and she picks up on that
right it's it's like the game right it's
like the dating game that's kind of how
this works i mean whatever whatever your
fancy is if you're looking for something
long-term or something short-term it's a
dance right there really is no
difference between the human you know
mating process and like birds in the
amazon there's no difference there right
it's just how it is we go about this
dance and so sweet son is ultimately
kind of like all right let's see where
this goes right and so ultimately the
biggest issue that you have here is that
while alars and swisson are able to like
clone eternals they're able to
genetically engineer and create eternals
they cannot actually reproduce any
turtle they cannot produce a child of
their own through conventional means
laying down with each other doing the
damn thing and popping out a kid nine
months later they can't do it right it
just doesn't work for them and so what
you actually end up seeing here is the
arrival of kronos right of course kind
of the father of the eternals and in
fact one guy who had basically achieved
a level of godhood right chronos is
essentially a cosmic entity you only
ever really see him involved with the
eternals themselves but he still is an
astronomically powerful being and so one
of the things that happens is that elars
approaches him and says like we need
your help in procreating and he tells
them it's a mistake what you're trying
to do here is not the way you were
designed it's not what it's for you have
to trust the celestials knew what they
were doing but at the end of the day the
response of allah is i don't care right
our desire is like my desire a part of
this experiment is to see can we
procreate the the fact that the earth
was almost completely conquered by the
by the deviants because they could
procreate and we couldn't which
inherently reduced our numbers presented
a credible threat we need to know if we
can actually do this you are a being of
cosmic power you have the ability to
remove the blocks that exist in our
genealogy that would allow us to
procreate please will you do this and so
the response of chronos is yes but i
will not have a grandson out of wedlock
right like you need to get married and
go through the whole process and he says
i'll even provide the rings what's crazy
about this is the rings he gives to
alars and sui-san are the quantum bands
which is crazy now the reason why this
is crazy is because in years past in
mama comics specifically if you go back
and you read jim starlin's old captain
marvel run in issues 28 and 29 from 1973
one of the things this did is it dealt
with like the history of like the
eternals and you know them on titan and
thanos and all that kind of stuff right
that was back when thanos was getting
the cosmic cube and trying to destroy
everything but the other part of this is
you never saw this particular reference
because this is a new introduction the
quantum bands historically have been
given to individuals by the cosmic
entity eon who you actually see here
that tree looking thing uh they've been
given to individuals for the purpose of
allowing them to be protectors of the
universe and the quantum bands
themselves actually derive energy from
the quantum realm and in marvel comics
the explanation of the quantum moral is
simply that all energy that makes up the
entirety of the marvel universe is based
in the quantum realm right it comes from
the quantum realm so while the rings
themselves can only hold a finite amount
of energy the amount of energy that can
be put into the rings is infinite right
so it's like a cup that can only hold so
much water but the water that you're
putting into that cup is limitless right
so that's that's how this kind of thing
works and so because that is interesting
to see here now the quantum bands as
they're provided here seem to be more
ceremonial than anything else but it's
still kind of a cool little reference to
see with regards to the history of the
quantum band's use in the marvel
universe but one of the things that
kronos also says is that given his
knowledge of time and all things in
existence that basically they're gonna
end up having a boy and so that's kind
of the crazy thing is because they end
up basically finding out that they're
essentially going to have like two sons
and the first one they're going to name
eros who they're going to name for their
love and the second one they're going to
call thanos which is their triumph over
death and so it's kind of a cool thing
here right it's an interesting concept
to see how it is that it came that way
now of course one of the things is told
to us and we're kind of given this quick
little ramshackle explanation with
regards to suicide and we can fill in
the gaps here is that of course nothing
really went the way that it was supposed
to that elars had seen the idea of
eternals being able to procreate as
ushering in what was in effect a new era
kind of a golden age with eros yeah that
was the case i mean he was kind of a
dick and he would use his power to emit
pheromones to basically manipulate
people but all in all eros was largely
harmless he was really more interesting
and more entertaining than anything else
especially when he operated as a
superhero star fox with thanos as you
guys know that was not the case and as
soon as sui-san gave birth to thanos she
realized how horrible and how evil
thanos was going to become and actually
tried to kill him of course that led to
her being thrown into what was basically
an insane asylum on titan itself and
then of course thanos eventually caught
up to her when he was being manipulated
by mistress death as a little kid and
then ultimately killed sui-san and that
in turn basically gave rise to him
eventually showing back up on titan
after having amassed a colossal army and
then raising titan in its entirety and
basically killing everybody there which
is really really cool because force you
know what i want to do here for a second
i want to tie this into the mcu right
let's talk about the the marvel
cinematic universe first look at how
this would work here's one of the cool
things to know thanos gave us a great
big huge explanation on the history of
titan and why he's doing what he's doing
who's to say he was telling the truth
right i mean thanos is largely
considered to be the sin of titan now i
will say that one of the the best
statements made in the marvel cinematic
universe by nebula is that one of the
things thanos is not is a liar and even
in marvel comics it's not really that
way largely because thanos has no reason
to lie right lying is something people
do when they're afraid of the
consequences for what it is that they've
done but when is thanos ever been afraid
of the consequences for what he'd done
if anything he like he cherishes the
idea of what he does right like blinking
out half the life in the universe in his
mind he did it for love why would you be
fearful of that and why would you have
to lie about it so you know taking those
two things and kind of merging them
together you can largely go with the
idea that thanos may have on some level
than telling the truth but i wouldn't be
surprised that because of the recent
eternals run constantly referring to
thanos as the sin of titan the mistake
of titan different things like that the
likelihood that he may have in some form
or fashion been kind of manipulated by
mistress death or just driven by his
obsession with death which was really
teased at like the the post-credits
scene of the first avengers movie that
may come to fruition in the mcu i'm i'm
sort of curious to see how that's going
to play out the important thing here is
that because of what had happened
because of the fact that basically
allars takes it upon himself as a as a
personal guilt in the sense that he and
sui-san gave birth to thanos who is
basically the harbinger of death in the
universe that there was really no
undoing this and seeing it as a great
personal mistake and error he actually
tries to give the rings back to uh back
to chronos which is really more of an
act of defiance or opposition more so
than anything else but ultimately as we
know thanos catches up to to mentor
catches up to his father and then kills
him and so what ends up happening is
that as soon as that happens he's
resurrected in the exclusion zone now
this is something that we've never seen
before right this is totally new
completely undocumented stuff right this
is the first time we're seeing this in
the history of marvel comics he's
basically brought back by icarus and all
those guys really the great machine more
than anything else and the question is
how did the experiment go right like can
you report the result of the experiment
that you engaged in and he's like
eternals should not breed and in truth
the response is you are to be excluded
right and the reason why he's being
excluded here is not so much the fact
that he chose to try to find a way to
get eternals to procreate it's because
of the nature of alar's that no matter
what they do no matter how many times
they mind wipe him it seems to be in his
nature to basically deviate away from
the status quo and so if the eternals
were for example to find some way to
actually destroy thanos and they were to
essentially mind wipe alars and allow
him to be reborn without any knowledge
of his past mistakes he would likely
create another thanos and even if he was
allowed to live and thanos was seemingly
left alive and that even if his mind was
wiped that he could potentially create a
new thanos right that it's in his nature
to experiment it's in his nature to
break away from the status quo he
presents more of a danger than he does a
benefit and so when the question's asked
when he's taken to his exclusion cell
and the question's asked you know
where's sui-san is she still alive like
was she was she you know brought back by
the machine just like me the response of
icarus is yes but she does not want to
see you she's in her cell just like you
are and she said it would be better if
we had never met more so it would be
better if we had never existed and so
what ends up happening inside this cell
is basically a person seems to be met
with their own personal torment their
own personal failure in this instance
the cell itself is completely dark but
the penalty that that alars is paying in
this cell is that a pixel is going to
show up right a pixel is going to appear
and each one of these pixels represents
a person that thanos has killed and so
basically he's going to live here in
this exclusion cell so long as earth
exists until the time that earth is
destroyed he will stay here and
seemingly when earth is destroyed he'll
die along with it this is the this is
basically a prison he's going to be in
for the rest of his life or until such a
time the decision is made to release him
that's likely not going to happen but in
everything he's seen because of how many
people thanos is killed he's ultimately
surrounded by just this bright burning
light which burns his eyes out of his
head and he's basically just left there
right this is his fate is to just stay
there and suffer inside the cell
seemingly for all eternity but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end honestly this story was
amazing i love this i love stories like
this where they go back and tell like
the history of things i love those kinds
of stories of marvel comics i've always
loved history itself so this is really
fascinating to me let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
and i will catch you all later
peace
you